-Hola, Sal. -Hola Brit. -¿Cómo estás? -Estoy
bien. Parece que tenemos un juego por aquí. -No
es un juego como tal, es una pregunta-desafío para
ti. Lo que hice fue poner un grano de arroz en la
primera casilla. -Es cierto. -Hay 64 casillas en
el tablero. -Sí. -Y en cada casilla consecutiva
dupliqué la cantidad de arroz. -Ajaaa. -¿Qué
cantidad de arroz crees que haya en esta casilla?
-¿En esa casilla? Déjame pensarlo un poco. Aquí
tenemos un grano de arroz, y lo multiplicamos por
2, así que aquí habrá 2 veces 2. O no, no, no, no:
2 x 1. ¿Qué estoy haciendo? Ahora, en la siguiente
casilla, tenemos 2 veces la cantidad anterior.
Entonces tenemos 2 x 2, aquí tenemos 2 veces esto,
ok. Empezamos a tener muchos 2 por aquí
multiplicándose entre ellos. Aquí tenemos
2 x 2 x 2, y estoy intentando escribir de lado; y
este será 5 doses multiplicándose entre sí, este
será 6 doses multiplicándose entre sí. -Aja. -Por
acá, tendremos 7 doses multiplicándose entre sí,
8 doses multiplicándose entre sí, 9 doses
multiplicándose entre sí, 10, 11, 12 y 13.
Así que todos estos doses multiplicándose entre
sí, lo que nos da 8,192 granos de arroz. Eso es lo
que deberíamos de ver justo aquí. -Y, ¿sabes?, tuve
una noche divertida. Estuve despierto hasta tarde,
pero aquí los tienes. -¿Realmente contaste
8,192 granos de arroz? -Más o menos. -Ok,
digamos que lo hiciste. -Y si fuéramos cuatro
pasos adelante, ¿cuánto arroz habría aquí? -Cuatro
pasos adelante... Entonces tenemos que multiplicar
por 2, después multiplicar de nuevo por 2, después
multiplicar de nuevo por 2 y, por último,
multiplicar de nuevo por 2. Así que es este
número por... veamos: 2 x 2 = 4, por 2 = 8, por
2 = 16. Entonces nos dará algo como 120 o 130 mil
aproximadamente. -131, 672. -Tuviste mucho tiempo
anoche, y eso que no hemos llegado ni a la mitad
del tablero. -No, no hemos llegado. -Este es un
montón de arroz, podrías organizar una fiesta.
-¿Qué hay de la última casilla? Son 63 pasos.
-Multiplicaremos 2 x 2 y vamos a hacer 63 veces
esto. Esto será un número enorme, y, de hecho,
sería genial si existiera una anotación para
esto. -No conté este número, pero el montón de
arroz sería del tamaño del monte Everest y podría
alimentar a 485 billones de personas. -Pero,
tengo una pregunta, quiero decir, ya sabes,
fue un poco molesto para mí escribir todas estas
veces 2. -Así fue esto. -Si yo fuera la comunidad
matemática quisiera un tipo de notación. -Ya
casi lo tienes. Me gusta esto de punto punto
punto y el 63, esto puedo entenderlo. -Sí, puedes
entenderlo, pero esto sigue siendo demasiado. ¿Y
si, en cambio, escribimos... -Los matemáticos aman
ser eficientes, ¿cierto? Son flojos... -Claro,
tienen cosas que hacer, tienen que ir a casa
a contar granos de arroz. -Cierto. Ja, ja,
ja, ja. -Perfecto. Entonces, esto es 63 doses
multiplicándose entre sí. -Esta es la primera
casilla del tablero; tenemos un grano de arroz
y lo duplicamos: tenemos dos granos de arroz,
los duplicamos de nuevo y tenemos cuatro. Y
pienso que esto es similar a lo que hicimos,
sólo que está representado de distinta forma. -Sí,
bueno. En este que estabas haciendo, cada vez que
agregas estos palitos, te estás ramificando: de
un palito de paleta salen dos palitos de paleta
y sigues haciendo esto, de un palito de paleta
salen dos palitos de paleta; pero ahora tenemos
dos de ellos. Entonces tienes uno, después tienes
1 x 2, y después cada uno de estos se ramifica en
otros dos, entonces tenemos 2 x 2 o 4 palitos
de paleta. En cada paso, en cada ramificación,
estás multiplicando de nuevo por 2. -Básicamente,
te sigues dividiendo como lo hace un árbol. -Sí.
-Ahora podemos ver cómo se ve 2 elevado a la
tercera potencia. -Y es lo que tenemos aquí:
1 x 2 x 2 x 2, lo cual es 8. -Por lo tanto, si
vemos 2 elevado a alguna potencia, digamos n,
entonces n también puede ser el número de pasos
hacia arriba en este árbol. Podemos pensarlo de
esta forma. -Cierto. Creo que una forma de
ver esto es cuántas veces te has ramificado.
Pero este otro árbol es aún más interesante. -No
creo que este cuente, ya que de nuevo se ramifica
cuatro veces en cada rama. -Bueno, espera. ¿Por
qué no? Es diferente: ya no tendremos más al 2,
pero en un inicio la primera rama no se ha
ramificado todavía. Esto será 4 elevado a la
potencia 0. Aún no tenemos ramificaciones. Aquí se
ha ramificado una vez, así que tenemos 4 elevado
a la primera potencia. Tenemos cuatro ramas.
-Me gusta. -Y ahora, cada una de estas ramas
se ramifica en 4 más, ahora se ha ramificado 2
veces: este es 4 elevado a la segunda potencia.
Así que sí. Llamamos base a lo que elevamos
a un cierto exponente, en este caso es el 4.
Esta es cuántas nuevas ramas saldrán de las ramas
anteriores en cada intersección. -Sí, llamémosle
intersecciones. -Intersecciones. En un inicio, no
nos hemos ramificado, después nos ramificamos una vez
y después dos veces. -Esto es interesante. Por
eso cuando miro un árbol, hay miles de hojas,
pero un solo tronco. -Así es. -Y cuando subimos y
observamos dentro del árbol sólo se ha ramificado
tres o cuatro veces. -Y eso nos muestra el poder
del crecimiento exponencial. -Sí. Ja, ja, ja.